all right so we're going to talk about
what to do
if you have calcification in your
arteries
i've done other videos on this there's a
really good test
that you can do to determine if you do
have calcium
in your arteries in fact it's one of the
best predictors of mortality
so i'll put a link down below for more
information on that if you
are not familiar with that test but this
video is on a protocol that i would
recommend
to help undo the calcification
in your arteries of course the best
thing is to prevent it
but what do you do if you actually have
calcium buildup in the arteries
all the things that i'm going to talk
about are not meant to replace your
medical care
just do your own research i put some
links down below for every single thing
i'm going to talk about
the first natural compound is allicin
which happens to be the phytonutrient in
garlic
some real interesting research on the
association of
allicin and decrease artery
calcification
in animals so if you have a pet with a
calcified coronary artery
start feeding them garlic immediately
number two
butyrate now what is butyrate butyrate
is a compound that
your microbes in your gut make
when you feed the microbes fiber and i'm
going to recommend
vegetable fiber but it is actually a
type of fat it's a small chain fatty
acid
that's produced in your gut from
microbes
from vegetable fiber and that too
is associated with a decreased risk
of artery disease now number three
lycopene this is a phytonutrient
in tomatoes it's in a lot of other
vegetables
and there's some real interesting data
of showing how lycopene can decrease the
thickness of the wall of your arteries
and also decrease the stiffness
and this is why sometimes you'll see
some crazy
claims that oh now you can have ketchup
and it's going to decrease your
risk for heart disease because ketchup
has lycopene
of course we know that's not going to
happen now also if you add
olive oil when you're cooking it can
greatly increase the
amount of lycopene up to 82 percent
and that is because like other
phytonutrients
lycopene is a fat soluble compound
which means it requires bile and adding
more oil into the diet
can greatly enhance the absorption all
right number four
omega-3 fatty acids the sabian fish oils
definitely cod liver oil which i
recommend more than fish oils
i mean we know that omega-3 is good for
so many things but its
main action in relationship to your
arteries
is the decrease in inflammation but it
can also
increase the risk of getting a clot now
on the flip side
the omega 6 fatty acids increase
stiffness of the arteries and it can
increase the clotting factor
and when i'm talking about omega-6 i'm
talking about the soy oil the
corn oil the canola the cotton seed
now there is one type of omega-6 that is
very friendly to your arteries and it
doesn't increase
inflammation and that would be called
gla
or gamma linolenic acid
this would be like borage oil black
currant seed oil
evening primrose oil
so gla can help decrease inflammation
it can help decrease thickness in your
arteries
it can also decrease the plaque
formation
in your arteries i put some links down
below very very interesting
all right number six vitamin k2 you
probably knew this was coming
i would recommend getting the mk7
version
and i would consume about 300
micrograms every single day now what
does vitamin k2
do it activates a certain protein that
inhibits
calcium from forming in the arteries
so that's a very very important one
number seven
tocotrinols tocotrienols is one
form of the vitamin e complex
and it's about 50 times stronger than
tocopherols
and it can greatly decrease inflammation
in your arteries
it can decrease something called
c-reactive protein which is an
inflammatory
compound by 40 and lastly
and most importantly is doing whatever
you can
to decrease and reverse
insulin resistance there's a direct
relationship between
having insulin resistance and having
calcification
in your arteries and so a lot of these
other remedies
are not going to work unless you also
correct insulin resistance how if you're
new to my channel
i put the link down below you need to do
healthy keto
and definitely intermittent fasting for
a period of time
to start making changes but it's my
opinion that the combination
of addressing insulin resistance with
tocotrienols with k2
with allicin and omega-3 are probably
the most important things you can do
and these other compounds are are also
good but i think using them
more as a secondary approach thanks so
much for watching i'll see you in the
next video
before you go if you have a question
about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto
or you're on
keto and you need a debug because it's
not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help